plus d'une demi douzaine de médailles
lors des jeux olympiques de tokyo c'est
le bilan des yvelinois lors de cet été
2011 21 11 athlètes du territoire était
engagé principalement triathlon avec
trois représentants du club de poissy et
à la clé une médaille de bronze par
équipes mixtes l'équipe de france de
relais rentrer dans l'histoire avec de
triathlon rentrer dans l'histoire
puisque nos quatre triathlètes dans
quatre relayeurs noms de garçons à nos
deux filles ont su ont su apporter cette
médaille que tout le théâtre en français
attendait quand on sait que bon le
triathlon a fait son apparition en 2000
à sydney
il a fallu attendre intervenants pour
avoir une médaille deux médailles de
bronze également cyclisme notamment pour
le saint quentinois florian gréng ball
lors de la vitesse par équipes en
équitation christopher 6 de gaz rend
termine également 3e avec son équipe en
concours complet on c'était ma première
olympiade donc ce qui n'était pas le cas
de mes deux camarades nicolas touzaint
et karim laghouag donc mois déjà bah
fallait que je fasse mes preuves auprès
du staff fédéral leur montrer que
que j'étais capable de tenir la pression
parce que sur les jeux olympiques on a
la pression surtout que là maintenant
notre discipline
les règles ont un petit peu changé
depuis cette olympiade là avant il y
avait quatre concurrents qui couraient
les trois meilleurs scores compter et là
en fait on est trop à courir les trois
corps compte donc en fait on n'a pas du
tout droit à l'erreur autre discipline
autre succès claire beauvais revient
avec l'argent autour du cou elle est la
première licenciés du club de monte à
obtenir une médaille depuis quarante ans
les yvelinois ramène également deux
médailles d'or le handballeur versailles
et vincent importe remporte la plus
belle des distinctions avec son équipe
tout comme guillaume chaîne du club de
sartrouville en judo en catégorie équipe
mixte des judokas célébré à leur arrivée
à paris on a été accroché par les
israéliens au premier tour je pense que
voilà c'était un élément déclencheur est
là tout a basculé derrière ça déroule
c'est très sexy en diable on voit tous
ces français rassembler les membres de
votre club à sartrouville le vice
président du club ça fait plaisir ça
doit faire chaud au coeur bien sûr mais
de toute façon ça fait déjà longtemps
que je sent l'engouement qui a derrière
moi je sois au club de sartrouville
enfin même la ville tous les a retrouvés
loi change vraiment qu'il ya un élan
phénoménal derrière moi et et oui je
pense que il ya un an donné où ça a dû
me pousser sur cette olympiade quelques
déceptions lors de ces jeux sont aussi à
déplorer en golf le versailles et
antoine rosemère 84e joueur mondial ne
termine pas sur le podium tout comme
maiva hamadouche est licencié à saint
quentin en yvelines en boxe depuis la
création des jeux le département
totalise maintenant 36 médailles un
chiffre qui pourrait encore grimper un
peu grâce aux athlètes paralympiques
pour la compétition se déroulera du 24
août au 5 septembre